the homescreen of a website or the
loading screen of your mobile app will
be the first impression for users and
you want to make sure that you get this
right here's Udacity s homepage as of
April 2015 a clear goal headlines the
page and there's plenty of white space
around the headlines and the tag line to
draw users into them home pages like
this one should answer these questions
what is this what is being offered what
can I do here and how do I start in
Udacity z' case that how can I get
started comes just below the fold with a
description of the nanodegree program
you want all of this information to be
present but you should also be careful
not to overwhelm your users you want
users to have a clear understanding of
what you offer and then you can link to
other pages for users to learn more
about your product or services many
companies put those links in the footer
going back up to the top of the homepage
we can see that from here I could sign
up for an account or I could sign in if
I'm an existing user to learn more about
how nanodegrees work in particular I
could click on one of these home pages
are tricky and that they need to do a
lot but you want to be careful about
adding more and more to the page so
sometimes you might have a landing page
like this one lending pages are for
specific products that you want to show
to your users they allow you to focus on
one particular product notice that here
there's a clear call-to-action I can get
a sense about what this product is from
the copy on the page and also from this
background image scrolling down I can
even get more details about the program
to learn more about designing home pages
and landing pages check out the articles
that are linked in the instructor notes
at the very least you need to strive for
an informative page and at the best your
home page should be memorable it's
important to keep in mind that your home
page doesn't have to be static it should
be a work in progress here's another
version of the Udacity homepage and
notice that it's changed slightly we
have different copy and these images
have been condensed together your home
page might also be dynamic and that you
might be a be testing certain features
of it to see what drives users actions
you might also just be trying to refine
your value proposition for your users
and even before that home page this is
what you dassey's homepage look like
once upon a time
as you can see it's not as informative
or clear at answering the questions
what is this and what can I do here at
the end of the day you want to make a
fantastic first impression it's really
up to you to delight users so that way
they come to know who you are and what
you have to offer now it's your turn to
do a little investigation of your own
I'd like you to find three home pages
for relatively new companies and analyze
them you want to get a feel for what
type of information and elements live on
their home pages for each of the home
pages you should ask yourself what
elements comprise the home page what are
the main calls to action what does that
home page say about the company its
users and the value proposition and what
are the most likely flows from the home
page to other places on the site in
other words what could you do from the
home page finally what are some of the
similarities and differences you see
across the home pages you looked at
write a post that answers these
questions and share it on the
discussions once you're ready check this
box to continue